one year ago today after months of
thinking and planning and some
procrastinating I shot and uploaded my
first video to this channel it's not
that just as an experiment and honestly
I wasn't sure if anyone would care or if
anyone would benefit but I figured it
was worth taking the risk and so I
started filming my lessons and putting
them online I didn't own a fancy video
camera so for a long time I shot my
videos on an iPhone but I needed a way
to keep the phone upright and so I went
down to the wood workshop at my school
and I made this it's just three pieces
of wood start together with wood glue
but you know it did the job I put my
phone in the middle and then I would sit
that on top of a chair on top of a table
and I'd plug it into a microphone and
all my other videos were done like this
after a while I did I didn't upgrade a
little bit and I got a hold of this
which is a case that has a a hole in the
side where you can screw in a tripod so
you know it would go like that as you
can see that case is slightly broken and
I would carry around a tripod that I got
given as a parting gift by I'm some
graduating is CF leaders so thank you
class of 2011 that's how I did it for
quite a while and it was good though
there were occasional hiccups like when
I got a call in the middle of a class
and stopped the video or the multiple
times that my battery gave out because I
forgot to charge the night before then
earlier this year I got an iPad and I've
been using that ever since I get lots of
odd looks and I know it does seem
slightly awkward to have this thing
carried around and put on top of a
tripod but I love it because I can shoot
and do basic editing and upload all from
the one device and as you can probably
really know I upload quite a lot of
videos on average of three every day for
a whole year and so everything I can do
to make things a little bit quicker
helps speaking of numbers to my surprise
in this first year I've reached and
passed a thousand subscribers and a
hundred thousand views on my videos now
I know that isn't that much in the sort
of YouTube scheme of things like one of
my favorite channels Freddy W I think
they hit 1 million subscribers in their
first year but when I've realized when
I've thought about the fact that
you know I'm making videos about high
school maths and technology rather than
like viral videos about action or
explosions or comedy I think it's pretty
amazing that anyone who's subscribed at
all now even though I started this
channel to help others I want to share
with you a big lesson that I've learned
myself over the past year because of
this channel and basically that is if
you want to start something if you've
got an idea then the best thing you can
do like rather than start preparing and
arming and hiring is just get going give
it a shot it's gonna be pretty lousy to
start with and if you like me it might
stay Lau's you for a while but what
surprised me over and over again is the
fact that even though what I've been
doing is really simple and really basic
and there's lots of videos out there
which are much much better lots of
channels which really professional that
kind of thing it's still been really
helpful to people and that amazes me
like I'm not a super experienced teacher
this is I've been teaching you for six
years now and where I teach you know
there's quite frequently people who get
their certificates for 20 years of
service or 25 or whatever so I'm
surrounded by all these amazingly
skilled people I'm still learning a lot
myself and I'm just sort of a baby in
that way but the little contribution
that I've been on make is Verrill help
people and I think a lot of people out
there watching are able to do the same
thing you might not think of yourself as
much but if you get started give it a go
you might be really surprised by what
you're able to accomplish so I want to
say thank you to everyone out there for
joining me on this journey here's to
many more years and many more helpful
videos